Write six hundred forty-five
million five hundred
eighty-four thousand
four hundred
sixty-two in standard form.
So let's tackle this
piece by piece.
So the first part we
have six hundred
and forty-five million.
So let's think about that.
So we have six hundred
and forty-five.
But it's not just six
hundred forty-five.
We have six hundred forty-five
millions.
So we could view that as
645 times 1,000,000.
One million is one followed
by six zeroes.
So this piece right here is
this right over here.
That is six hundred and
forty-five million.
And what is that when
we write it out?
If we were to multiply this
out, this is equal to-- it
would be 645 times this 1 with
six zeroes behind it.
So this would be equal to 600--
I'll write it like this.
This is equal to 645, and then
we have our six zeroes.
One, two, three, one,
two, three.
That's just this part
of the number.
And I'm going to do it kind
of slow and do all of the
different parts of the problem,
but once you get some
practice, you'll find that these
are a bit second nature,
and you won't have to go through
all of these steps.
You'll just be able to
write the number.
Now, let's move on
to the next part.
We have five hundred
and eighty-four.
Let me write that down.
Well, I'll write it like this.
584 thousand.
So let me write the thousand.
So 584 thousand.
So it's 584 times 1,000.
And what's that going
to look like?
So that's this whole
part right here.
So 584 times 1,000
is equal to what?
Well, it's going to be 584 with
three zeroes behind it,
or you could view it as 584
times the 1, and then you're
going to have three zeroes
in the final answer.
So it's going to be 584,000.
We have our three zeroes
at the end.
584, three zeroes.
So that's that part.
And then finally, we have four
hundred sixty-two, and that's
just 462, straight up.
You could view it as 462 ones.
So then you just
have 462, which
obviously equals just 462.
Now our number is all
of these combined.
It is 645,000,000 and
584,000 and 462.
So one way to think about it
is that you could add these
three numbers.
So if we were to add them,
we get 645,584,462.
Now, I said it'll become a
little bit of second nature to
you in a little bit, and the way
to think about that, the
easiest way to think about that,
is millions will have
six zeroes behind them,
thousands will have three
zeroes behind them, and just
regular numbers have no zeroes
behind them.
So what you can do when you
kind of want to learn it
second nature, you'll just look
at the six hundred and
forty-five million, so you'll
write 645, and you'll kind of
keep in the back of your mind
that you're going to have to
have six more digits to
the right of this.
And then you say five hundred
and eighty-four thousand, so
then you have your five hundred
and eighty-four
thousand, so then you write that
down, 584,000, keeping in
mind that you're going to
need three digits to
the right of that.
And so if they didn't tell us
462, we would just put three
zeroes here, and that would also
fulfill the six zeroes we
need behind 645,000,000.
But then they tell us 462, so we
just write that right here.
462.